dude that is crazy visual clue that is
crazy you wouldn't pick it up
what's up reject nation we are going to
watch today a video i've been wanting to
watch since we started squid game
because i wanna know what the heck this
title was possibly implying every ending
clue
that spoiler things you miss and hidden
details obviously i believe this is
hinting towards the fact that the old
man was really behind the squid games
the entire time
uh this is heavy spoilers paul's biggest
video he's ever done just in a matter of
a couple weeks congratulations to you
brother you've grown like 60 000
subscribers or something in like a week
so proud of you man so proud of you
check out his channel he's been
obviously killing it so let's see what's
going on all the hidden clues that we
did not catch because man that was a
damn good show and of course you could
check out all our reactions are now up
here on the channel
[Music]
okay so did you know that the players in
squid game could have actually seen what
games they'd be playing before they even
played them between the matches the
characters were all placed into a room
filled with bunk beds and though this
seemed just like a rest area if you look
at the walls they're actually filled
with significant markings as the beds
get slowly stripped away last episode
[Music]
playing throughout the tournament
green light there's also the honeycomb
game tug of war the glass hopping one
the three at the table and lastly the
team no way
already there are so many clues
staring at the players at least in plain
sight because they said it's like all
the beds are being moved away to know
that the clues were there the whole time
because so much of them were like what's
the next game we got to prepare
ourselves what's the next game that
could have helped damn that's pretty
gnarly to know is right there the
full-time clue
and honestly i never noticed this entire
time watching the series itself is
filled with clues to the eventual
reveals and this is also the case with
the player who's behind the entire thing
it's absolutely mind-blowing and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down but i just want to
give a huge spoiler alert for the series
if you haven't checked it out then this
is your chance to quit playing but if
you want to continue then i hope you
thumbs up the video and also subscribe
to the channel without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
squid game
okay so at the end of squid game we
learned that it was ill nam all along
the final episode reveals that he
invented the games as a form of
entertainment for him and his rich
buddies who had become bored with life
we learned that he had actually got
involved in the one that we see in the
show because he was dying and wanted a
final bit of fun in his life before it
was too late the ending was absolutely
incredible and the scene had jihan
saying goodbye to the character as he
lay on his death bed i did hear because
we've been saying gihon or jihan but
i've heard some people correct us saying
that it's probably key hun okay i mean
geez are kind of proud of the k i will
take any tip i can get it's
still wrong
i'll i'll make that until i get
corrected again i don't know we're not
korean we don't speak korean this last
meeting actually reflected their first
one in which he too encountered the
character as he sat in a bed it was a
pretty big twist that pulled the rug out
from under your feet but eagle-eyed
viewers might have spotted early on that
there were several clues pointing
towards his true identity the first one
is that he is number one the very first
player if we look at the subtext of the
series g-hunter is the final number and
throughout he watches he very much works
his way to first place aka ilnam in the
final episode he's left as number one he
inherits a large portion of the
character's fortune and comes face to
face with him in one of the final scenes
one is symbolic on a number of levels
and because it's the first place it also
hints to us that illnam is number one
and that he's the one controlling
everything in episode five huang jun ho
sneaks through the compound and he
eventually finds a storage room with
files on all of the games that have
happened over the decades upon opening
the 2021 the first player there is
actually number two and illness profile
is completely missing there is no file
for number one because he doesn't
want to keep a record for himself oh
crap
yeah that's a great deal that's solid i
was trying to keep up with the dates so
i wasn't sure exactly which manual we
pulled from if this was exactly our game
that we were watching or this was a
different one because they mentioned
they were going around worldwide yeah
that's
that's kind of staring you in plain
sight at that moment yeah i know it's so
quick you're like oh maybe just open to
page two yeah yeah once you examine it
it's crazy and you're already processing
so much other information during that
scene oh that's hilarious oh it's good
video
no wonder this video did so well for you
paul the other players in the game also
somewhat hint towards us that something
is off with illness and though it's not
too obvious when you really think about
it he wouldn't be someone that would be
selected for the process everyone else
in the squid game is roughly the same
age whereas he's extremely elderly he's
also dying of a brain tumor and thus
even if he did win the life-changing
money it wouldn't last that long though
he gives his reasons as to why he wants
it but what we know about the games and
the players that have been selected in
the past are all roughly between 20 and
40 and he's a complete outlier in all of
this and the games themselves are also
major giveaways too throughout the
series we watched as he said they were
all things that he'd played as a child
and in retrospect it becomes blatantly
obvious that he selected them himself
because they're what he knows on repeat
viewings it's clear that each of them
are something that he not only played as
a kid but there are also things that
he's very very good at the first thing
they play is red light green light
whilst the other players are absolutely
terrified for their lives he gleefully
struts about whilst the terminator's
back is turned and even stops before it
looks back to face the crowd he knows
all of the lyrics to the song that the
machine sings and therefore knows to
stop in advance before it ends and turns
back around if we look at the clip of
the target players you might also notice
something different about him the one
directly to his left and all of the
other ones to the side have a slight
green overlay that appears over the top
if we look at the players to his right
outside of the girl crouching down
beside him this is also the case too
everyone other than him in this girl's
track suit appears slightly green and i
believe that this machine sees him
without the glow because it's been
programmed not to shoot him if this
theory is right then he also has a
protective ring around him that stops
the machine from firing at people in his
vicinity in case it misses and that's
why the girl to his right is awesome
dude that is crazy visual clue that is
crazy and you wouldn't pick it up
because i thought the biggest indicator
in that moment when they revealed it i
think one of the first things i said was
that's why he was smiling because that's
what seems off he's smiling the whole
game too like every even after like tug
of war is laying there grinning his ass
off but that particular game stood out
to me because this is everyone's
exposure that this is a life and death
situation that you will die if you do
not successfully play this game that's
why everyone's terrified and he isn't
you know it's easy to just chalk that
moment up to he's just a senile old man
he doesn't really get what's going on
he's just playing the game but it always
did strike me as a little bit odd that
he wasn't at all phased by the death
surrounding him in that moment but oh
that is a that is a solid ass clue right
there holy crap immediately after this
game the players decide to cast a vote
on whether they should end the
tournament or not he is the one who
makes the choice in the end and casts
the deciding boat to end the game this
subtly shows his power over the entire
thing and i actually think that he
carried this out for a specific reason
he wanted to give the players a chance
to walk away from all-knowing mistakes
and if they came back then that would
ease his conscience slightly as the
choice was theirs yeah i thought he like
mentioned that in his deathbed that was
a big part of like you guys chose to be
here that seemed kind of intentional
yeah absolutely that he wanted them to
select to come back that he and he
actually knows they would come back but
it was that part of the confrontation
with kihan in the end of it all was to
lay that dope line
that's about the smartest part of his
entire plan if you
make it out and then you still want to
go to the authorities it's like you you
agreed to go yeah you signed away your
life you wanted to do this i cut to the
honeycomb game and illness ends up
choosing the star though this seems like
a very complex shape there's not
actually any bends in it like the
circles or umbrellas though you might
think it's easier to have the triangle
the triangle's lines are longer whereas
the stars are shorter so there's less to
cut through before you hit an edge being
completely honest though yeah the
triangle is a pretty easy shape too but
illness didn't exactly have one of the
difficult ones either next we jump to
episode 4 in which your fight breaks out
during the night throughout illna hides
away from the carnage up on one of the
bleachers and he ends up begging for the
fighting to stop even though up until
this point it seemed like the front man
was completely in control he immediately
sends the guards in because illness
requests it another clue is that his bed
is the only one that isn't flipped and
this is because the gods likely know who
he is next they play a game of tug of
war and because of their players it
seems like ilnam's team are about to be
sent to their deaths however he is the
one who tells them how to win and
because of his guidance they easily beat
the much stronger team illness had
clearly played the game hundreds of
times before and knew the best strategy
to take any team with him was destined
to win and the fact his strategy works
definitely proves this yeah the final
game
is the marvel's one and this also has a
lot of clues in it throughout it it
seems like the character is struck by
dementia and he constantly walks around
looking for his house this game not only
pulls from his childhood but the area
does too and unless the squid game
organizers were psychic then they'd have
no way of knowing what his home looked
like throughout the episode everything
he says is brushed away is the ramblings
of someone with the disease but knowing
what we know it becomes all the more
obvious that he's in control in the end
he seems to find his home and personally
i believe that this is the perfect
recreation of it he's giving the game
away because throughout the entire
season he's letting us know that all of
the challenges and environments are
based on things from his life he lets
jihun win and the character is then
seemingly killed off camera but we know
that isn't the case yeah we look closely
at the gate that jihan has just walked
out of we can see that he's no longer
there and though the rest of the court
is filled with bodies his is completely
missing
knowing what we know a question you may
have is why did ilnam end up leaving the
game such a well framed still invested
in playing because you can't do the
points the next game is the deadly
hopscotch one and this is by far the
most unpredictable of the lot if he
didn't end up getting put in last place
then there would be a danger that the
person behind him could push him to his
death like what we see in the episode
there's also the possibility that due to
his brain tumor he may have forgotten
along the way which glass to step on and
he simply couldn't risk it also just
like physically you have to have
incredible balance to be able to
jump from glass to glass and if you have
that level of fear of the of the heights
and such i'm surprised no one just
botched to try to jump from one last
next yeah cuz i i feel like in my
situation i'm pretty coordinated when it
comes to something like that but if i
have enough fear running through my
brain and body i might not be so focused
that i i might i might botch uh my next
jump even if it's the right glass to
land on yeah they spaced them far out
enough that it's not like you know a
good wide stride just step on it yeah
yeah you have to make that choice and
yeah for him i'm like
how many jumps do you got in your buddy
yeah i actually think the series becomes
better on a second watch now obviously
i'd love to hear a few spots pretty
great our first watch soon and if this
is your first time here then i hope you
enjoyed your trip to the heavy spoilers
show dude great work paul man i'm sorry
that that one for the red light green
light that one blows my mind yeah
yeah
it's right it's kind of staring you in
the well that's what i think what's good
about a lot of them is they are kind of
staring you in the face there were like
little things that made me suspicious
along the way especially if you watch
our reactions of like you don't seem to
shout on camera why is he always happy
something seems a little suspect
honestly when i was seeing like
thumbnails going around for illness i
was assuming that it was about like oh
what was leading to his death
not what was leading to the ending
reveal but what i love that you pointed
out here especially is how his reunion
with gihon
is reflective of the first encounter he
has with gihon yeah yeah i actually
didn't draw that parallel but that's
always really cool because i thought the
last episode is already doing kind of a
parallel of the first one to show the
arc of kihun but even showing that
moment too yeah that was great that was
great absolutely congratulations paul
has an amazing ass video guys subscribed
to have you spoiled this video and done
so already he's really struggling right
now you can subscribe to us hit that
like button last but not least
maria hammond maria we actually shot and
edited a whole shout out for you for the
final episode of what if that's why i
was rocking that shirt that you gave me
the black panther one and i was like
saying all these nice things about you
applaud export didn't realize it until
way after it was uploaded the whole
shout out actually wasn't exported along
with it in the final file because we
could do like three files for this and
uh i'm sorry you're still getting
shouted out here and i just want to say
thank you because you uh have given us i
think about four thousand dollars worth
of items right in the past month i don't
know why you're not just selling them
for yourself because you might end up in
this position where you have to compete
in the square games which you would win
oh yeah you would definitely you're a
tough cookie you would probably you'll
probably just kill everyone while
they're sleeping and they'd be like
you're the winner knowing you that's the
way there you go killed 455 people yeah
still
no one suspected or woke up or hurt a
thing you know fair rules everyone was
under the same conditions maria just has
that cunning instinct
[Music]